[Music]
all right welcome back to careful boys
we are very careful boys indeed today so
careful today we have bart quan
so
you got a crazy story what happened so
uh two days ago
one of my buddies was a police officer
here
he calls me
and he was like hey can i stay at your
house tomorrow and i'm like and this one
i'm in vegas and i'm like what the [ __ ]
why do you need a camera for you guys
it's i'm like are you coming here to
kick it or whatever is it here are you
uh coming for work
and he goes this is for work
i'm like
okay
so he comes uh he stays and i'm like
don't you guys have [ __ ] per diem or
some [ __ ] like like the [ __ ] stat a
hotel like why'd you either like because
you couldn't sneak out at your [ __ ]
deal with this partner and [ __ ]
i'm like don't you guys get purdue
because i was in the military i
understand like if you do like off-base
[ __ ] they'll pay for your sheriff
jerusalem he's trying to save us for dm
duh so what he told me is not on this
case but it's such an urgency
because
um what happened was there's uh certain
hotels like in the hood where they
charge by the hour
right so you kind of know the kind of
activities that go down there
and there was this one but this one dude
with a hispanic girlfriend
they're going into
this parking lot in the hotel
and they get into like a parking lot
fight like right before they're about to
park some other person comes parks in
front of them takes their parking lot
the hispanic girlfriend comes out starts
talking [ __ ] to the person it was a
chick who was a chick uh that parked the
car so two chicks are going at it
the
girlfriend's boyfriend comes out of the
hotel room and goes what the [ __ ] is
going on of course the hispanic chicks
boyfriend comes out and goes mind your
own goddamn business get out of here is
that a gun or is he pointing oh
get out of here get the hell out of here
like a disney employee what are you
[ __ ] crazy
leave yeah he's like
he's like get out get out of here please
pointing is rude so it's your fingers
keep in mind this is the hood so things
can escalate is this in vegas no this is
in l.a keep in mind this is a hood uh
thing's gonna escalate very quickly so
he says mind your own business get out
of here
the other dude
pulls a gun out and he goes well
give me your cell phone because that's a
thing because that's good that's it can
you hold it like you're good
oh [ __ ]
that yeah things escalate quickly so he
pulls out a gun tells him to empty his
pockets uh pull give me your cell phone
and then he pushes the gun into a guy's
mouth knocks out all of his teeth wow
and then because i guess that guy was a
like a crazy criminal so he's looking
for any anything which guy is this now
the the guy who came out of the hotel
room
because he got he told him to mind your
own business so if you're from the hood
you don't like hearing that kind of [ __ ]
so it's like you don't like it i'm
telling you so now it's time for a
robbery because you heard you told me
some things i don't want to hear boom
all the teeth pop out
um
and then uh
that chick that came out of the hotel
her homegirls come out they
jumped the [ __ ] out of the hispanic
chick beat the living [ __ ] out of her so
now the boyfriend and the girl i think
they can tell that uh these two are on
the verge of death so they get a rental
car and they drive and they flee to go
to vegas so that's where they leave the
parking spot
yeah they're like i don't care about
finding spotty more
they leave for vegas it was everything
for a while
it was worth it it was everything to you
they left the car too they left the car
and then um
so of course people are gonna report
this crime there's two people that are
hospitalized all this crazy [ __ ] and
then
uh when they when that name was uh when
they returned the the rental car in
vegas this guy's name rings up so of
course you know they have they have like
they're still model citizens bringing
back the rental car because i don't want
to be overcharged
in pristine condition so cops say you
know they talk vegas metro tells the
police department over here hey these
guys they just uh
they just showed up over here um do you
want us to run surveillance they're like
yes because i think once they found out
who once they id'd this person this guy
is extremely dangerous
so they run surveillance they find out
the house that this guy was kicking it
in and they go okay we know where his
house is and we've seen his whereabouts
in this activity do you guys want us to
detain them which means they're gonna
need a warrant they're gonna need the
swat team they're gonna need to like
pretty much like some training day [ __ ]
you know knock down the door they're
like they give them the green light
so they do it they go they go boom they
[ __ ] they break down the house grab
the dudes this guy's in custody in vegas
um so my buddy and his other partner
they're like okay cool we have to go get
him right and then his buddy
who didn't really file a warrant yet
gave them the green light without it
happened
and so he was like [ __ ] you have
to get a warrant because you can't just
break people's houses down the street
because it was training day
yeah
so the law is i think the law of
extradition to grab someone from some
other place uh you have 30 days so you
can like jump the gun because some
criminals are just that elusive but you
have to have in 30 days you have to come
up with the paperwork or they're gone
so that's why they finally just got the
paperwork and that's when they their
whole department got greenlit and then
that's when my buddy called me and i'm
like oh [ __ ] i'm like are you is this
going to go on the back of your police
car like what the [ __ ] is going on he
goes no it's going to be is he going to
stay at my house
stay in my guest bedroom i do have bunk
beds you can [ __ ] that was our place
am i allowed to talk about this on my jk
video for real dude the whole time
you're saying this i'm like should we be
talking about the race that's why you
don't that's why i don't know which
department you don't know which
department on next vlog you see him on
bart's couch like this and tyka's
throwing balls at him
bad guy this video is used in the
courtroom
so they uh yeah so they um so he
that's why it was that's why it's
immediately they they come to get them
and then i'm like is he riding back in
their police car and they're like no uh
we're part of the convoy because they
think they might get even get ambushed
on the way back the convoy
that's how important this guy is yeah
that's how crazy this [ __ ] is
i'm like damn that's some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] dude but then they're talking about
like this is a daily occurrence like
this i'm like how deep are you guys in
the criminal world where it's just
ambushed when he's [ __ ] telling me
this [ __ ] i'm like man this is [ __ ]
crazy dude well it's their job every day
he's like no it's just tuesday so he had
to stay at your place yeah just for a
quick night and then in the morning
because i guess their like armored
vehicle or whatever is leaving at 4am
and then uh my buddy and his partner has
to do all the paperwork and make sure
everything's cool before like
that convoy arrives the picture so what
you're saying is you're an accessory to
justice oh that's literally what i
texted you're [ __ ] hot so i texted
geo because when my friend called me i
was like i texted her i was like hey do
you want to be on the good side of
justice
she was like huh i'm like do you want to
serve justice she should have blocked
your number like what kind of sexual
[ __ ] is this
i've got a role playing and she's like
huh and then i was like she's like don't
beat up tyka's friends
can
blank
sleep over she's like yeah i'm alright
that's so funny so they had the whole
command center in your house
yeah just two people imagine if there
was the armored car everything we use
bart's room for the [ __ ] cell
what's dope is uh my name is space dude
my neighbor across the street he's
[ __ ] dope because they come late i
sleep at 10 right so they're like we
want to drink some whiskey and smoke
some cigars i'm like go ahead i'm gonna
go to sleep so they parked right now
that's how fun it is at barton for real
bro goddamn is it fun eight o'clock it
was like you and ryan you have to go to
bed
so they were taking it they were kicking
it outside of their their cop clothes
regular civilian clothes in front of my
house
and then what my buddy told me was that
guy who lives across the street he has a
glass door he's just like staring at him
the whole time and then my buddy and my
uh his partner were like well we don't
want to disturb the neighbors so he's
like let's put out our cigars and go
back inside so as they're packing up and
they're about to move this guy is now in
the middle of the street like they're
like standing there yeah like a scary
movie yeah and then they're like you
guys want to smoke some cigars
so he was like oh hey how's it going sir
and then he walks up and he goes what
are you guys doing here and then he was
like oh um uh i'm friends with the owner
and then he was like what's his name and
he goes bart he goes okay and he goes
and then that's when my friend was like
he pointed at the driveway he was like
oh we're police officers why because
they had a cop car there yeah oh he's
like oh
i didn't even he's from the south so
he's like oh i didn't even notice i got
my four to five here
ready and i was like damn my neighbor's
dove knows you ain't no asian fella
what kind of asian are you so i figured
you was related to the wife
[Laughter]
my neighbor's dope as i texted him all
that yo thanks for looking out for my
house he goes i was like it would have
been funny if in the morning i was like
hey did you see two guys rob in my house
he goes not on my walk
you gran torino monks are okay with me
i like how he's not even stealth you can
see him through the glass door this
guy's not good at it and then he's in
the middle of the cul-de-sac like
just a gun in his pocket that's crazy
that's dope man he's a good neighbor
or his ghillie suit is a mannequin of a
man
[Laughter]
with a flammable shirt of jeans today's
video is brought to you by upstart if
you got multiple credit card balances
each month and you're just getting by by
paying the minimums barely making a debt
in your credit card debt can be pretty
damn discouraging upstart can help you
pay off your existing debt quickly so
you can finally feel like you're getting
ahead whether you're paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan with a five minute rate
check you can see your rates up front
between loans from one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars and you can receive
your funds as fast as one business day
after accepting your loan find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today by going to upstart.com off the
record that's upstart.com off the record
and don't forget to use the url so they
know that we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided on your loan application go to
upstart.com
off the record so did they catch the guy
yeah they got it they're good and they
they had they had they got the son of a
[ __ ] yeah but then the prosecutor is
probably going to let him go because he
saw this video well and the reason why
the uh case got escalated so much is the
hispanic chick who got the [ __ ] kicked
out of her she was three months pregnant
so now so now it's like a murder for
sure yeah and then oh my god wait murder
for sure because the baby died so that's
so they [ __ ] up the
damn yeah that's for sure murder and
then whatever thing they're gonna add on
top of it that's terrible right yeah
this is sad man now this is for sure
patreon
[Laughter]
we got to put this
sure we're tampering with evidence you
guys set up any cool equipment in your
house like any stakeout equipment did
they use your wi-fi and see how fast it
was yo his wi-fi is [ __ ] fast dude
that's how that's why they wanted to get
they want to get the paperwork quickly
let's go to parts trust me it's gonna
upload real quick that's why it's like
the picture of the back of a police car
on my instagram
where i was like i got arrested for
stealing hearts oh
[Laughter]
oh they drove their squad car there yeah
they're they're undercover i literally
thought you just asked the police
officer hey can i uh
i did i thought i did no i'm not
somebody you knew like so a random
police officer is like i have this funny
i take a picture here matters dude why
didn't you clickbait the [ __ ] out of
that video you should have done a whole
vlog and everything what do you mean
honestly what do you mean what do i mean
who's in the middle of an investigation
this guy's on the right side of justice
now oh yeah but you're a tuber you could
be in the back you know tubers always
get the back of the vehicle
yeah they're always like oh boy i got
arrested and then the the thumbnail's
like i got arrested
before i tell you the story hit the like
and subscribe
but it's always in that voice too if you
guys like this video do a thousand likes
right now don't let me go
i like how they do that live but it's a
recorded video but yeah you do it right
now you know why
it's [ __ ] seven-year-olds
and they think they're actually like
interacting with it sometimes it
actually works though sometimes
that's what we should be doing appealing
to seven-year-olds yeah this is where we
[ __ ] up on youtube everyone knows that
when you make content for
seven-year-olds you crush it on youtube
how would we make it okay how do we
adjust this video right now at the 12
minute mark for seven for seven for any
seven year olds washington we need a
jingle there needs to be a jingle
and i think we need color in our clothes
we need slime all over us and [ __ ] yeah
anal be no that's adult again
they won't know the difference it could
just be beads
yeah yeah yeah we can't do kid's
concepts okay we horned it out so he he
said beads but we don't know what he
said yeah
yeah so we don't know the beets but they
don't eat them kids should know about
their bodies can't be [ __ ] talking
about beads
i think that's fun kids
because it is anatomically correct right
that's what they call it it's anal
cavity right
yeah this is [ __ ] crazy though it's
like you know when you're going on these
little road trips to vegas right like
would you ever think sometimes there
might be a cold-blooded killer in a cop
car like right next to you on the road
that's all about all i think about
because it's such a dark road it's like
two lanes
[ __ ] scary [ __ ] out there and all the
mafia movies you watch you're like how
many bodies are just [ __ ] buried out
here you guys have dark souls because
i'm thinking about should i get a krispy
kreme donut or not because i'm going to
get fat if i do don't get it from
terribles i got it from terribles oh
that is tar buzz it's cold yeah that's
why it's called can we get a little bit
dark and hypothetical real quick all
right let's do it let's go for it so
like obviously these dudes uh this guy
uh who [ __ ] had the bazooka this
isn't about donuts no
the bazooka guy kind of [ __ ] up right
because they go to vegas and then they
return a rental car and that's what
pings the system and that's and then
they go to a house because they're under
surveillance from a different
jurisdiction blah blah blah blah right
so how how would you escape such crime
don't get a rental car why would he get
a rental tomorrow get a stolen car
already has a gun
haven't you played gta yeah you got to
get into your car can you imagine this
who beat the [ __ ] out of someone and
then they drive into hertz and then they
go all right let's ditch the car i would
like to rent one rental car please under
my government name please
here's my idea it's a credit card and he
goes all right escaping the law don't
[ __ ] me i'm getting insurance okay if i
get a little dang i'm gonna give you
[ __ ] by you guys they should have
stolen the car from the people they beat
up because they already [ __ ] murdered
them anyway yeah they should have stolen
their car and they're like low job on
that [ __ ] dump it somewhere else steal
another car but i also think it's when
you have criminals that
have done it seven thousand times you
know your level of care is like
yeah so now it's so now it's at the
point where they're like i don't want to
drive my own personal car add 200 miles
on it i'll just i'll just go rent a
random car you know so you're like their
radar is so low that they're not
thinking oh this is my first crime how
do i get out of it but do these guys not
play grand theft auto because literally
it's the easiest
you drive into the train tracks and you
hide in the tunnel in the tunnel that's
it or you go a painting spray yeah oh
that's right you go to the painting
and then when you drive back out the
cops don't even see but that takes
forever you gotta lose the cops to go in
the pan spread yeah and actually go into
a train tunnel with a car it's the
easiest [ __ ] ever and just wait wait
until the stars go down that's it that's
the hardest thing about being a hip-hop
based criminal though is because you
have to live by the i don't give a [ __ ]
mentality oh yeah
mob guys give a [ __ ] that's true yeah
yeah oh so this guy was a mob guy this
guy's like hip-hop he sounds
hip-hop-based they don't ever rap about
enterprise or anything
that's true but i think the craziest
part is that the cops are like we need
to do a convoy because we might what's
someone's going to [ __ ] ambush them
on the way back they'll try to break the
dude out yeah yeah what [ __ ] do they
arrest [ __ ] dominic toretto
and then also
is there a convo a convoy going to be
going like regular traffic too though
because there's only two lanes so it's
like you're stuck is your convoy just
chilling or they go there
let's be real don't cops kind of
escalate [ __ ] like crazy sometimes too
and like make [ __ ] like way too
seriously sometimes yeah just to make it
cooler just like dude sometimes i'll see
like literally 90 cop cars i'm like holy
[ __ ] what is going on it's just one guy
sitting on the street with his [ __ ]
hands
and even that guy's like do we need this
many cops yeah he's like hey how many
times can you shoot me
if you go to a city like irvine it's
like that because they don't really get
caught were you here yesterday dude why
because we titled all these
conversations about irvine and how many
cops there were oh and you're bringing
it up because everyone gets pulled over
at irvine by 10 cops have you been uh
pulled over in irvine as a kid a lot
yeah and it's just and it's a kid like
three or four [ __ ] cars yep yeah yeah
what do you mean what were you doing not
as an adult hey what kind of [ __ ]
shenanigans are we doing just [ __ ]
driving around listening to trance
[Laughter]
but he's a kid like a five-year-old
and then they go what ha what kind of
priors have you had rape yeah did they
ask me that did you ask me those
questions
that's basically what he said to me the
first thing they pull me out of the car
they go how many times you've been
arrested before and what what what what
are your priors rape i just wish that
guy talked like that the whole time what
kind of soda do you like great
like he just goes down the line of every
[ __ ] thing i'm just like what the
[ __ ] dude what kind of soda do you like
[Laughter]
that's what they do ask you when they
pull you over and [ __ ]
never ends i get it but what's your
favorite moment you could have started
with like
jaywalking wow i i got a ticket for
jaywalking one time you did that's like
the [ __ ] crime i've ever heard of i
didn't know people actually get a
jaywalking are you you're not hardcore
enough to get one brother how about that
you just run and the cars can't go where
your feet can go okay i'll tell you this
you just act like you're jogging and you
don't see him okay it was
it was literally out of the scene of
like harold kumar where he steps on the
curb and he's like there's no cars it
was like seven in the morning i just
finished training a client
oh and i'm walking to a coffee shop
nearby
and i usually never this is what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass i am even when there's
no cars i wait for the light what why
that's one of those weirdos
he's from california and the one time
the one time i was like
oh okay so i'm gonna do it i was at a
crosswalk yeah was that a crosswalk but
there was no [ __ ] cars except a cop
car i don't even know where the cop was
bro he wasn't even i think i literally
look did he light you up like
that no i walk into the coffee shop i'm
waiting to order
and i'm like and then it goes like this
yeah it's the barista yeah yeah he's
like you're arrested and i was like what
no this guy taps me on his shoulder and
he goes can i see you outside for a
second
but yeah
you should have said no and part of me
was like
okay
because i'm [ __ ] dumb yep
i walk out with him and he goes um you
just jaywalked and i go huh
and he goes you have to give you a
ticket i'm like
seriously oh
dude and he just gave me a ticket was
this the irv he was it was in pasadena
that's an irvine cop in pasadena yeah
and he was an asian dude bro and i was
like
but the fact that you pulled me out of
the coffee shop and i'm like bro i'm
[ __ ] in this area like i work here
all the time like i why are all the
asian cops so on it with the rules man
yeah because they're [ __ ] losers bro
the last guy that gave me a ticket asian
cop dude if i see that fool i'm a
[ __ ]
i think there's a little bit of asian on
nation they expect the best out of us
they got to go harder on the asians and
[ __ ] you know because they're like he's
just laughing i love it what's your
theory what do you think what i don't
know white cops just hug me all day
they go hey check out my dad man
i missed just being called the racial
slur at least they didn't give me a
ticket yeah
oh yes yeah hurt my feelings not my
wallet god damn dude that tickles like
300 bucks dude one time i got pulled
over though and i was 300 for jayla i
was running like 30 minutes late for
this thing i got pulled over
and these cops pulled me over and
they're like hey dude your windshield's
like all dirty and then they started
cleaning my windshield
they took the pepper spray out
i got pulled over by this lady cop she
was really cool she goes um she goes hey
you're speeding
uh i'm not gonna give you ticket
because i saw you had a twinkie in there
and if that twinkie is strawberry i'm
just gonna let you go and i was like
dude it's not it's just a regular
twinkie and she goes i know no one eats
the strawberry ones and then she just
leaves what is your life a [ __ ]
sitcom dude you're a sex timer too man
yeah did you have sex with his lady cop
or something she wanted to suck your
twinkies
i had a [ __ ] uh you're so charming i
had a game boy in the car like the
[ __ ] or the nintendo ds in the car
and she goes you playing some karate
game or something
[ __ ] playing some karate games young
man
[Laughter]
did she really say yeah
yeah that's really funny
i didn't know make sure
she was super she was super cool and
honestly you know what the difference is
that
like when i assessed all my because i
get pulled over a lot but my uh why my
assessment whatever tell me i'm always
doing something wrong
i admit i'm always he gets away with all
of that when i'm driving an american car
like when i had my camaro cops were
always [ __ ] cool and then when i'm
driving my civic is never cool he's one
of us yeah
hey
you have to collect some funko pops
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you